100
um with this project what just off the
top of your head man what's your
favorite song
uh my favorite song
probably man all these songs I like my
babies man
um
I'm gonna tell you what my least
favorite song was at first
and I didn't even
um
I ain't even want to like do it you know
what I'm saying and
and it's crazy because like it's from
one of my favorite producers seven
Thomas and I ain't even like the beat he
gave me some heat he gave me a lot of a
lot of [ __ ] on this album but this one
this one in particular I was like I
don't want that one I was like that
don't sound good for me and then Lambo
kept [ __ ] [ __ ] with me yeah kept
[ __ ] bothering me I was like bro he's
like rapping this beat rapping his beat
rapping his beat I was like hey look man
you leave me the [ __ ] alone dog I'm on a
roll right here dog right I'm in the
studio with this I remember the night we
was in the studio with DJ Paul he's like
okay yeah you did that one now [ __ ] with
this one and I was like no [ __ ] leave
me the [ __ ] alone
and then we was in Miami and then one
day I was just like listening to the
Bone and then I was I don't know I was
in a Groove and he played that beat and
then I forgot that's our landlord a
magician with this [ __ ] I forgot that
that was the one he was bugging me about
and then I was like he just let time go
past and I was like oh this [ __ ] hard
yeah after a while my ear had to open up
and sometimes that takes time that's why
I don't like when [ __ ] like
Rush album you know what I mean because
it's always something that somebody else
to hear that you're not hearing you know
what I mean and um you know and I hear
artists all the time like yeah this is
my album my album my album yeah my name
on the [ __ ] album but it's really all
about albums really me my album Lambos
out more vase out and we made this [ __ ]
together you know what I'm saying like
you tell me the offset record that's the
one I'm talking about like I wasn't
gonna do that record at first and that
ended up being the record that offset
wanted to get on you know what I'm
saying but at first I was just like uh I
had my doubts about it because my ears
are probably tuned into something else
and then they just like allowed me time
to tune out and then when they brought
it back around
it's gonna be a hit record you know what
I'm saying so it's like
you know I think that a lot of these
things too
um are our Collective efforts you know
making a a great body of work making a a
good album you know I mean a lot of
rappers might not have a team I got you
know I mean so they probably can't make
the album that I make because they're
just going off of their own ear and
their own emotions nobody is uh you know
directing them in any kind of way you
know I mean not to say that you can't be
the boss of the situation but I feel
like you gotta you know you need a team
you know what I'm saying Michael Jordan
needed Phil Jackson you know I mean it
got to be it got to be somebody on the
court I mean off the court looking at
[ __ ] like hold on man you don't see this
because you know eat my eyes when I when
I don't got them you know he see [ __ ]
that I can't see also your Instagram
when you don't got it that too that too
all those guys right shout out the level
shout out to Norway you know he made big
plays on his album you know we all it
was a real Collective effort you know
shout out to Chris Atlas and Warner you
know I mean my man Chris don't get
enough credit but uh you know I think
that we all
stuck thy strengths you know I mean I'm
the best rapper so I just stuck to that
you know um I didn't try to deviate from
that and I wanted it you know I didn't
try to like make no beats like [ __ ] I
don't make no I'm not Anderson pop right
you know what I'm saying like Anderson
Parker wrap your ass to sleep play the
drum play the drums
yeah he's a maniac I am not on his level
whatsoever you know what I'm saying but
I totally respect it that's why I had to
get him on the album but you know I just
stuck the world out you know what I know
you know what I'm saying I'm a I'm a
scorer in that regard you know and I
just you know locked in like Kobe